wow you are gucci you need to dress the
pot
welcome to your weekly ticket
ghostbusters afterlife had a
spooktacular debut weekend the sequel to
the original ghostbusters films earned
44 million dollars at the domestic box
office that makes afterlife the eighth
highest debut in 2021 but that hall is
even more impressive because the film
only costs 75 million dollars to make
the family comedy which stars the
reigning people magazine's sexiest man
of the year paul rudd marks the biggest
opening for director jason reitman
[Music]
sylvester stallone is headed back to
guardians of the galaxy three stallone
who plays captain staccar oh guard in
the franchise confirmed the news sharing
a behind-the-scenes video from the mcu
set director james gunn confirmed that
filming started back on november 8th
when he shared this photo from seth
the photo shows gunn dave bautista palm
clementife sean gunn chris pratt karen
gillan and zoe saldana joined by new
cast members will poulter who will be
portraying the cosmic character of adam
warlock and shikuri uwuji whose role in
the film has yet to be announced
denis villeneuve confirmed that harkin
and villain fade ratha will appear in
dune part 2. in a recent interview with
empire velanoov explained his reasons
for omitting the character from the
first installment saying there were
enough characters that were introduced
in this first part and it will be more
elegant to keep fade for part two it
will definitely be a very very important
character in the second part
zendaya timothee chalamet rebecca
ferguson josh brolin stalin skarsgard
dave batista and javier bardem are all
expected to reprise their roles from the
first film and jonah hill is set to play
grateful dead front man jerry garcia and
martin scorsese's latest project
scorsese will produce and direct this
untitled biopic though details on what
part of the band's story might be told
are not yet known the duo previously
worked together on the wolf of wall
street which earned hill his second
oscar nomination for best supporting
actor
in theaters this week is house of gucci
the film is inspired by the true story
of the family empire behind the italian
fashion house of gucci and the betrayals
therein
spanning three decades of love decadence
revenge and ultimately murder we see
what a name means what it's worth and
how far a family will go for control
house of gucci is based on the book by
sarah gaye forden and directed by ridley
scott and fandango correspondent nikki
novak sat down with the cast to talk
about the movie selma hayek and lady
gaga told us a hilarious story about
their bonding experience shooting a mud
bath scene absolutely
bonding moment that
we were so tired
it looks so beautiful and delicious i've
never had a bath mod bath before which
shocks
her how do you get to be your age and
not have a
something like this but when we went in
we didn't rehearse that because then
we're
all dirty and wash and go back in
when we went in this one goes in like
cleopatra like nothing
you know she knows how to handle her mod
she keeps talking we do the thing
she goes in perfect gorgeous
me
for some strange reason i start floating
like at this grace balloon you know i
can't get my ass to hit the ground
i'm going like this and my lines
underneath ridley is not coating he's
enjoying the the clumps
and uh she didn't in the scene provides
us to help me because
also my boobs are kind of like freaking
out of the mouth i'm trying to like go
in like this so i started flipping but
the hair it was so disgraceful and a
disaster but i kept saying the lines
and then of course
i had lady gaga teach me how to sing
in the mod
which is just
just
sit your ass down and don't move the
more you move the more you're gonna
float
and so
we tried it again
but that was that scene was so fun to
shoot because it's so funny there's an
intimacy that is perceived in that
moment that they're totally alone
they're talking about how you know the
muricio can't run the business and she's
you know i was sitting there i'm really
trying to focus on this one candle that
was at the end and there's you know 50
men standing around you we're trying to
have a close-up but not really when uh
sam was like moving all over the place
and i just was staring at this candle
hypnotized at what was what would what
could she possibly be thinking in this
moment where she says
well i can't say because i don't want to
give it away but it's an important
moment for super important moment yeah
time to clown around and she was
laughing and then she was making fun of
me that i was so serious and but this is
the camaraderie of two
uh actors and i i have so much respect
for selma and i learned so much from her
and you know the first time i ever spoke
to her she said to me
the
when you say supporting actress it means
something she said i'm here to support
you in your performance i never forgot
it she called me a couple weeks before
we started and it was so so kind and i
loved working with you but you know what
in our relationship pina was not
somebody sophisticated she knew how to
navigate that and pina really looked up
to patricia and pini pina wouldn't know
how to get into the the mod and of
course it would be patricia who teaches
her how to descend like le patra and so
every moment it was so funny because it
always worked it always went back to the
relationship between these two women we
were playing with
and it was such a delicious relationship
check out the rest of our house of gucci
interview with lady gaga adam driver
jared leto al pacino ridley scott jeremy
irons selma hayek
that's a big family on the fandango
all-access page house of gucci is in
theaters now
also in theaters now is in kanto
delivery
i gave you the special since you're the
only madrigal kid with no gift i call it
the not special special since uh
you have no gift
uh thanks
and kanto tells the story of an
extraordinary family the madrigals who
live hidden in the mountains of colombia
in a magical house in a vibrant town in
a wondrous charmed place called encanto
the magic of encanto has blessed every
child in the family with a unique gift
from super strength to the power to heal
every child except one mirabelle voiced
by stephanie betrice but when she
discovers that the magic surrounding the
encanto is in danger mirabelle decides
that she the only ordinary magical might
just be her exceptional family's last
hope
also available to watch at home is
spencer and venom let there be carnage
excuse me
yummy
tom hardy returns to the spider-man
universe as the lethal protector venom
one of marvel's greatest and most
complex dual characters
when deranged serial killer cletus
cassidy also becomes host to an alien
symbiote eddie and venom must put aside
their differences to stop his reign of
terror the film also stars michelle
williams naomi harris and woody
harrelson in the role of the villain
cletus cassidy plus if you're looking
for some movies to catch up on or some
shows to binge make sure to check out
our thanksgiving week sale going on now
through cyber monday our staff looked at
hundreds of movies for sale on vudu and
compiled the list of the best deals that
are going on past black friday from new
releases like the green knight and paw
patrol to generational classics like
clue and beverly hills cup our staff
picks thanksgiving week's sale has you
covered beyond those 100 voodoo has
thousands of television shows and films
that'll be on sale during thanksgiving
break gotta get those deals right arnold
okay well that's it for today but wait
before you go leave us a comment and let
us know what you'll be watching this
week i'm kale and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you